quand on a été la choriste de johnny
hallyday difficile d'échapper au
répertoire du rockeur en 2012 lorsque le
défi cap les elle se présente au casting
de the voice
elle cède à l'envi
une voix puissante qu'elle a mises au
service de gagner à l'idée pendant vingt
ans avec lui elle a fait bercy le stade
de france des tournées mondiales en
passant par le stade de dillon en 1999
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
jess comme on l'appelle dans le milieu a
chanté également avec barry white mylène
farmer ou le groupe boney m
elle a chanté aussi en solo comme ici en
1992 au festival de jazz de pointe à
pitre avec une interprétation très
personnelle
d'aretha franklin
[Applaudissements]
baba
komara
quoi
[Musique]
à
concert également en solo en 2014 au
petit journal montparnasse un club de
gaz par ici
[Musique]
étonnant destin que celui de cette
martiniquaise qui est né au lorrain a
grandi au marigot est parti à paris où
elle a d'abord travaillé comme
secrétaire
avant de tout plaquer pour devenir
chanteuse très affecté par la mort de
johnny hallyday en 2017 des sicap les
elle s'en va à son tour pour allumer le
feu gentiment là où